hello and welcome to this episode of the
future verse brought to you by
Intelligence Squared and white tree I'm
come on armid ytree was founded in 2017
to give its clients the transparency
efficiency and meaning so they can
understand their financial lives as they
are and as they could be today we're
introducing a new theme in the future
verse life transitions
childhood adolescence marriage divorce
becoming a parent losing a parent career
changes retirement life is of course
made up of transition some big some
small
we'll be digging into many of these over
the coming weeks
but we're going to start with Hobbies
now it's a word that can sometimes feel
a little bit silly one we often dismiss
demoting them to the status of a
frivolity or a Time filler but our
hobbies are often our passions our
interests and without these where would
we be
how would we weather the difficult times
or take advantage of our talents perhaps
even create the change in our lives we
have been looking for
I'm joined today by four amazing guests
to discuss how their passions and
interests LED them down more fulfilling
or exciting or dare I say it just fun
paths
so welcome to Alan russbridger editor of
prospect magazine and former editor of
the Guardian
he rediscovered a love for the piano
aged 40 and this hobby is at the hearts
of his Memoir Play It Again
Steve Cook is senior partner at
Slaughter in May a firm which counts a
third of the members of The ftse 100 as
clients
given that somehow he also finds time
for music spending his Sunday's
composing scores for films and
documentaries one of which when I'm a
bafta
and I feel we should have a drum roll
here or probably something more
musically clever our new futureverse
music is a Steve Cook composition
Emma Kennedy is a best-selling author
screenwriter actress and presenter she
won a celebrity Master Chef in 2012 is a
Guinness World Record holder for
organizing the world's largest kazoo
Orchestra at the Royal Albert Hall for
comic relief and that's just part of her
day job
Emma is also a Lego fanatic which she
shares with her Legions of fans fellow
adult fans of Lego via Twitter and
YouTube
and Mark gersheson who is founding
investor in ytree have been retired from
a successful career in property
investment he is now fully embraced his
passion for golf
and hopes to be on the amateur England
team this year
Alan Steve Emma and Mark welcome to the
podcast now Alan let's start with you in
your book play it again you describe
yourself as the archetypal amateur who
having given up the piano at 16 returned
to it in middle age
give us a little story into why you
started it gained your Mutual career and
why the piano became such an important
part of that
well I I think lots of us when we're uh
young do artistic things we we act we
dance we paint we
um we perform and then we grow up and
when when we uh we get proper jobs and
and all that falls away
but I I have a theory that it it never
really goes away and certainly when I
was in my late 30s early 40s it it
bursts back through and demanded to be
heard and I bitterly regretted having
given up the piano which I think is a
very common thing
and I started taking it rather seriously
and taking piano lessons
and I went on a piano camp in France
which was where this book began because
there were eight eight or ten other
people like me
um equally uh hopeless stroke Rusty uh
and
um I discovered that these hopeless
players could play really stunning
pieces of music and that was the origin
of my journey
and Alan you talk about I think this is
probably true for so many people
listening to this podcast who have been
through that Journey as you say of kind
of giving up
music or some kind of creative activity
you did outside what might be described
as your school work but then taking it
up often around that 40 year old while
what was it Adam that was going on in
your life then that suddenly because
it's often a time and I think it was
true for you particularly when you are
super super busy and you think I know
what would really help me here is to
take on a really difficult task
well I think it's partly I think this is
true of of some people if you have kids
um your kids get to an age round about
teenagers when I'm not going to say
they're they're they're easy but but
they're perhaps less demanding on us
that are hour by hour basis so you you
uh you perhaps have a bit of uh time in
the evening or weekends
but I I certainly found this that doing
a job as demanding as editing a national
newspaper which by then was being
published every day of the year round
the clock so that you were never off
just finding 20 minutes a day where you
switched off everything and did
something completely different
so it didn't use any of the skills that
I used in in editing it was a very
manual thing it used different bits of
the brain
and I've I found it a kind of um
essential Refuge I found if I had done
my 20 minutes in the morning of of
playing the piano
I was kind of ready for the day and and
days when I neglected it I felt somehow
less prepared so I it was a kind of sort
of nourishment as well as a hobby
and Alan I just want to actually read
just a small extract of the book and
then ask a question after it so this is
a small part of uh Play It Again
called it an escape call it a compulsion
but it felt like a physical need if I
could spend 20 minutes at the piano
before going to work I had a powerful
sense that the chemistry of my brain had
been altered
on the days I played my brain felt
settled and ready for whatever the next
12 hours would bring
so as you say Allen from that extract it
sounds like playing the piano made you a
better editor
so I decided to play Chopin's first
Ballard in G minor which is a piece that
terrifies many professional musicians
Vladimir Horowitz played it hundreds of
times and whatever stuff he he never
managed to play it right
um and the reason I played it was I was
on the on this piano cam with a guy who
I knew was no better than me uh and he
played it
um one evening and I just thought well
if he can play that must mean that I can
play it um and it took me 18 months to
kind of I wouldn't say master it
um the the reason I love the word
amateur is that it simply means for the
love of I mean it's become a a sort of
um a pejorative term are you you're a
rank amateur but actually amateur
musicians
um were were you know up there with
professional musicians in in just doing
things because of the love of it not
because you wanted to get paid lots of
money or win lots of competitions the
subtitle to your book is actually an
amateur Against The Impossible which I
think is a lovely phrase
um Steve could I come to you next also
interestingly music Steve could I come
to you next also interestingly music for
you was a vitally important and almost
your career in the early days those of
you aficionados of your music history
may have heard of the stereotypes I
think uh appeared on radio one at least
once if not more often could almost have
been your career Steve I just wondered
music's always been part of your life
and how is it sort of helped you in your
career as frankly an astonishingly
successful corporate lawyer it was like
Alan I I took out the piano at an early
age and gave it up at an early age at
the age of eight started at age of eight
also finished it but then tried to be a
rock star got played on daytime radio
one uh uh and thought what could go
wrong well it wasn't a hit and the band
broke up so I just sort of carried on
with this hobby which sort of gradually
became a bit out of control as we as we
actually started doing film and
television music and uh and that just
just carried on ballooning into into a
proper business
um but to your question how did it help
me on well it's very much like Alan it's
it was saying it's a different part of
your brain it's you're doing something
different it's a sort of diversity of
activity which I think helps you deal
with you know and what is undeniable in
my case a very you know pretty stressful
job working all hours of the day but
it's a different you know it's just
something different admittedly it does
sometimes become quite similar when you
have clients who are quite demanding or
you're not just doing it for yourself we
we once did a pot noodle advert and it's
the first and last time we'll ever do an
advert because the people are just too
annoying and actually the sort of music
you end up producing particularly for
this pot noodle advert is not actually
the sort of music you probably want to
be doing in the first place
but it might pay for uh a little bit of
the other stuff you want to do how do
you balance Steve the busyness of as you
say your career with
um being able to continue it much more I
think it's this idea of as Alan says
amateur being sort of a downgraded word
when it shouldn't be hobby similarly but
certainly not uh something that was your
Mainstay income although of course it is
a very important part of your profession
uh and your professional uh skills how
do you make sure you fit it in is there
a time like Alan said where he did 20
minutes a day how did it work for you
yeah I I you know I'm a person of to
some degree routine so I would make sure
that Sunday evening was the was the
evening for doing creating music and and
sometimes that's not a particularly good
way of doing it because you can sit down
at the keyboard or the guitar or
whatever and nothing pulls out of you
but actually quite often you're having
to write to a to a deadline produced to
a deadline which can be a bit stressful
but actually on the other hand it's you
know it's a bit a bit like my day job
you you just somehow seem to fit it in
and actually
not you know finding time to do it again
relieves relieves the stresses of of the
day job
routine I'm hearing from both Alan and
you was an important uh part of it
Alan can I come back to you when you
were having this period of of practicing
and relearning the piano but practicing
this very very tough deliberately tough
uh piece of work by uh Chopin it was a
time when the guardian itself was in the
headlines for the amazing journalism you
were doing Wikileaks for example the
phone hacking scandal I must admit as
someone who has been in journalism my
whole career the notion of then doing 20
minutes a day I mean how did you
maintain that commitment
well I think editing is a is a job that
can send you mad
um and and maybe we can think of
examples of addresses who have been so
mad by the by the job um uh because it's
so intense and because it is never off
and because it's so unpredictable and
there's there's always some Calamity
happening
um you know either in the outside world
or internally within the organization so
if if you let it overwhelm you uh it
easily would
um and I think another thing that
develops with with some editors is that
they have no outside frame of reference
at all the the job becomes the whole
thing
uh and I'm not sure they're necessarily
better editors for that
um so I in a in a way
um having this retreat
I I think help I mean you know most
former colleagues May disagree with this
but um but I think it stopped me going
mad uh and and enabled me to have some
degree of Detachment and perspective now
share with us you did actually play the
piece at the end of this period of
intense practice and learning how did it
go
um well I'd I began it and I ended it
and I was in the middle many of the
notes are in the right place
um
uh it's not it's not you would you would
not confuse me with vladimirovitz
um but in a sense that wasn't the point
I mean I went to interview Murray Pariah
the you know great great pianist
um
during the course of it um and he he
said
until the 1920s
um professionally there was no recorded
music and that the gap between the
professional and the amateur was
relatively narrow and then people got to
listen to their own recordings and
Perfection became the the goal of
professional music and now unless you
can play pieces
perfectly you you don't get a recording
contract and you don't get but I think
Murray thought that something had been
lost in that um
uh and so I didn't play it perfectly
but I but you know I did I played it in
the way that it it spoke to me and I
think uh although I wouldn't have wanted
Mari Pariah in the audience I think he
would have he would have seen the value
in this in this performance uh certainly
certainly not no perfect but but I I
think I played it with uh you know
meaning and emotion
so Emma there we've heard from two
pretty accomplished uh musicians uh you
uh found a love in a very different type
of Direction I think you were introduced
a Lego by your nephew tell us about the
Lego Journey for someone Emma who is so
creative and so much in that world that
Lego seems quite a change from the usual
things that keep you busy in your
so-called day job
so um I never played with Lego as a
child which is quite surprising that I
now find myself absolutely surrounded by
Lego but what happened about Four
Christmases ago I was staying with my
parents-in-law and my wife's nephew who
was eight at the time he came up to me
and he'd been given a a Lego set and it
was a very good Lego set it was uh the
the Darth Vader transformation set it
had very intricate moving pieces and you
could put Darth Vader in sort of the
burnt Darth Vader and then it twisted
round and you got
um helmeted Darth Vader and he put the
helmet on his head and it was that and I
was like wow this is like not what I uh
remembered Lego to be because I I sort
of vaguely remember going around to
people's houses and they would just have
great tubs of bricks but that was it
there was there was no sense that there
were these incredible and quite
technical uh sets that you could build
and I have a a brain that goes at about
100 miles an hour
and I found that when I was building
this set with my wife's nephew that it
just quietened down and it was like I
went to this incredible place
of Zen and I couldn't stop thinking
about how I had felt when I was building
that set and I came home and I kept
thinking about it and just kept thinking
out
I I can't I can't like
build Lego I'm an adult I'll have to
wait till next Christmas and and wait
for him to have another set and I'll
build something with him again and then
I just happened to see uh I was
following an author called Lissa Evans
on Twitter and she she just so happened
to post a picture of a Lego camper van
that she had just finished building I
thought oh okay great
um adults are allowed to build Lego so I
bought that same set the campervan and I
built it and it was it was like a a
gateway drug
to everything that was then going to
unfold it's a really beautiful beautiful
set it's got this fantastic interior
and
I was then given for my next business so
I then sort of started coming out as
somebody who liked Lego and I I could
have casually mentioned it to my wife
and and for my next birthday
she got me this incredible vintage Lego
set that you can't buy anymore not on
the primary Market you have to sort of
you know go to second-hand sellers to
get it which was the Ghostbusters
firehouse and it's well known as being
one of the greatest Lego sets of all
time and I started building it and it
was so fantastic and so incredible that
I started filming little
um like one and a half minute two minute
videos of what I had built that day
because I wanted to eke this out for as
long as possible and I started posting
them on Twitter
and
lots of people came back to me and said
oh you know we'd really love it if if if
you would film yourself doing an entire
build so that is how relaxed with bricks
began and it was really small at the
beginning with and I just just thought
you know I'd just do the odd set here
and there and it's just transformed into
this Monday to Friday
uh hobby uh that is that that I do every
single day now it's it's incredible
a new couple Emma I think it's called
relax with bricks
um for those of us who may be I I can
remember having exactly those
conversations with my son and my
daughter about Lego sets when they were
building Lego sets some years ago but
never actually connecting that with the
relaxation of doing it like as part of
my kind of life more generally than
simply at birthdays and Christmas but
for those of us who are rather less okay
with the wonders of Lego just talk us
through
maybe where it puts your headspace when
you're working on Lego that is maybe
different from how you work during the
day or at other things
so you know that sense of of quiet that
comes when you're doing a jigsaw so Lego
uh is like that but it's like a 3D
jigsaw there and so you can either get
uh sets of which there are hundreds if
not thousands and you'll receive it and
it comes with a booklet which uh which
which is of the instructions and that
tells you step by step how to build
something or you can do another thing
that I do which is I like to take an
existing set so that there is an iconic
Star Wars Lego set of of the Death Star
and then I like to pimp it up
so my version of the Death Star is the
death spawn I think you can you can you
can just sit over my shoulder over there
um so it's got there's a restaurant on
the on the lower level or on on on the
first floor there's a C-3PO who is
administering Botox to a Storm Trooper
there's another Storm Trooper who's in a
hot tub
um there there's a stag do that's going
on in a bar and then the upper area is
the HR department and and because I I
built that during the pandemic on every
single floor there are Miniature hand
sanitizers to keep everybody safe from
covid
and Emma but allowing you sort of join
together jigsaw making with massive
amounts of creativity and clearly Emma
humor for which you are also quite
rightly uh famous does it make does that
put in your sort of brain or your head
space or whatever it might be I don't
know you spoke about chemistry as you
say we're maybe not shorter maybe not
right to talk about that but does that
help your day job ever or all these
things melded together as one because
presumably relaxed with bricks is
probably pretty funny watching it with
you I think what it what it provides for
me that nothing else in my life does is
it allows me to play
and I think this is something that a lot
of adults have forgotten how to do and
I'm not talking about like sports uh or
or board games I'm talking about pure
playing
and I I remember once I was sent by the
guardian to a disused shopping mall
in Reading
and I spent three and a half hours
running around it being chased by
um other adults who were pretending to
be zombies and it was probably the
single greatest afternoon I've ever had
in my life and what I realized when I
was halfway through that experience was
that and I was looking around at all the
other adults who were also doing it and
they were like really really into it and
I realized what was happening it was
that adults were playing in the way that
children play and using their
imagination and just letting themselves
go and that is what Lego
uh does for me so you know with relax
with bricks this is what we do now on on
a daily basis we're essentially we are
playing I'm interacting with all the
adults who are watching it we come up
with all sorts of ridiculous and
fantastic stories we're playing
so there's a real emotional feedback
loop there with what you do Steve was it
was it important to you you said you had
this period in Sunday where you write
and you'd have obviously clients who
wanted music at certain times maybe not
pop new delivery time but others
hopefully slightly more successful
slightly more enjoyably from your side
of the fence at least
um was it important Steve that you had
that notion of the Target or the
commitment that kept you sort of honest
in your hobby so to speak if I can put
it like that although Steve to be
absolutely honest with you it's not
really a hobby is it it's an almost
another profession that you happen also
to be brilliant at out of control hobby
I call it
um
yeah it was it was sometimes important
to getting me to sit down at the
keyboard and and compose something
because I knew I had to do something and
and so that was that was good and
actually very often it doesn't you know
and sometimes it doesn't work sometimes
it does work and but very often the spur
of having to to write something means
you end up doing something particularly
when's it when it's not something you'd
write in the normal course you think
this has got to be in this sort of genre
or whatever and you and you listen to
you know other pieces you wouldn't be
copying them but you'd get inspiration
and those would and it so it sends you
down Avenues you wouldn't necessarily go
down on the other hand very often it's
just I just want to sit down at the
piano and that wouldn't be this kit here
it would be my my proper piano and write
something like that so it's different
inspiration sometimes you feel amusing
you and you go and do it but but having
the spur of having to do something
particularly where someone said actually
we want it to be sort of alternative
jazz with a bit of new metal throating
or something bizarre like that I'll do
this because it's fun it's just you know
why why am I reading a book because I
enjoy reading why am I doing something
else and that's just it's just something
like that I wasn't enjoying it I
certainly wouldn't wouldn't do it and
there's very very few moments uh when
I'm doing what is you know essentially a
bit of a business
um when I'm not enjoying it
and Emma back to you you've talked about
the death Spa which obviously I love I
believe there was also the Liza
Millennium Falcon see what you did there
tell us a bit about the other the other
builds you had
yes so so the Liza minnellium falcon
is very much an ongoing uh project so
this is another uh Pimp My Ride set that
I'm doing so I I have a natural
abhorrence of very large gray Star Wars
sets of which there are many in in Lego
and and I just I just refuse to do them
because they're just great big gray
lumps so uh my Liza minnellium Falcon is
is a vision in red and gold and white
and it has um there's a disco on board
uh there's a room uh uh for all her
outfits there's a washroom you know
again it's just exactly like I did with
the despot it's just it's just fun and
just letting my imagination run right
fantastic Emma Mark we find it music
we've had Lego I'm not that has many
skills uh within it ever I'm sure but
Mark we're going to come to to sport now
and golf your passion beyond your
fantastically successful career in
property investment talk us through Golf
and how it played a part in in your sort
of life and and how it became such an
important part of your life
uh goes quite an obsessive game I come
across so many people starting now at
our age that even wives of husbands that
resisted it for so many years and they
hit a few balls and suddenly they're
hooked
um I was a mad Sportsman as a youngster
and I found golf at 12.
um
in an unusual way actually I used to
have very terrible Asthma as a kid and I
was taken to the mountains
um for a treatment and there was a golf
range there and I've been playing tennis
up till that point and the minute I
started hitting the ball at 12
um I was hooked and I spent my
um my youth I suppose my teenage years
literally Dawn till Dusk every summer
holiday and Easter quite often
um traveling up to the golf club and
just wanting to improve and pottering
around the practice area in the second
nine and and just playing all the time
to try and get better and uh it's
there's so many aspects to golf it's not
just hitting a ball it's just every part
of the game challenges you both external
and internal it's it's it's it's just
it's a life's journey golf it's just
like like some other in every sport you
want to try and get good at but golf
really is a life's journey especially
from the mental side
and did you find Mark
similar to Alan that
you you do something when you're young
did you then give up and ReDiscover or
has it been something of a passion
throughout your life
it's been throughout but I gave the game
up twice
um once when I lost all my money in the
crash in 89
and once because I was suffering with
nerves in tournaments and stuff and I
just wasn't enjoying it and I wanted
just to do something that was more
enjoyable both times for three years but
when I finally came back to it
um over the years it's something that
I've just every weekend of my life I've
always wanted to do
why it's changed in the last few years
I've just hit my 60th birthday but
um
I wasn't willing to sacrifice my
business and work
to play all the time and the guys that
were really good I think did that
um and I didn't live on a golf course
so I you know I I didn't get much chance
to practice and I wasn't quite good
enough when I was in my youth to compete
on the in the major circuits if you like
as an amateur so it's only when I was
able to give myself more time in the
last the recent past so Mark yours was
very much a hobby that's more than a
hobby really that really was a
transition into that sort of what's
described as the retirement phase of
your life where you wanted to commit
your days to it in a way that for Steve
and Alan and Emma it's a slightly
different part of your life it became
what you did
yeah I mean I've spent two years now
three years uh it was slightly
um ceased for a year during covert but
I've had three years like traveling the
country playing tournaments which I've
never done in my life before and
although I I get what Emma says about
the Lego
um when I'm practicing and I'm in a hot
place or on holiday and I'm just on my
own it's the same thing it's you get
into a meditative state
um it's just you switch your phone off
you don't even care what's going on in
the rest of the world
when you're playing tournaments is a
different story and actually the goal is
to get into a meditative State because
the more you think actually the more it
hampers you so from my perspective I
spent a lifetime trying to curb
being a very fast thinker and thinking
of a million different things at once
and trying to not have all of this huge
amount of information that's available
to you on the golf swing and the
technical aspects of the game entering
it at the point where you actually just
want to perform and I've I've all my
life I've I from wanting to be a pro at
age 15 and not being good enough
and being persuaded to go down a more
education and professional route
um
now is the time where I want to see how
good I can get it's just about
fulfilling my potential
when when I can crack it and it's just
something that drives me and I
um and I and actually to a point where I
actually love competing now more than I
do just playing friendly games
he spoke Mark about nervousness coming
into your game and and meaning you
abandoned the game for a period of time
I think what's called The Yips in in
golf
um that sort of nervousness that affects
yourself in particular
but Mark talk us through that because
we've touched a few times on mental
welfare and actually
the notion of a hobby or for you a a a a
something you wanted to concentrate on
once your main career had ended how did
you tackle that how did golf help you
tackle the very problem that stopped you
playing golf
um
it was a combination when I wasn't
playing and I'd stopped
because I couldn't make apart from three
foot with two foot sometimes it sounds
absolutely extraordinary but that she
had a twitch in my hands that is a
habitual pattern that came in it's
called the IPS it's known in golf I
don't want to discuss it it's like
having said what they call the shanks
when you can't hit a ball off the face
of a club but um I had it when I was
young started when I was about 90 as 18
19. I had it about four or five times
actually over the years but uh fun
enough I did a lot of personal
development work else for business
actually
during those times when I uh from
Anthony Robbins I listened to loads of
books from famous people and I just
spent quite a bit of time trying to
quieten the mind and
um and using it's not just about
quietening the mind it's it's
transposing something instead of it so
it started when the long putter came out
and it was just something so different
from normal patting you could hold a
putter up here and and you wouldn't you
might feel it but the putter head
couldn't twitch and that gradually gave
you confidence that's why you see loads
of Pros on tour using a claw grip like a
that sort of grip instead of holding a
club normally it stops their hand
turning over because the the motor fine
twitch muscles
every time there's any form of nerves
can be affected the most and it's on the
putting and chipping the short game
where you need touch and you don't just
smash the ball that you you have to be
as relaxed as possible to be at your
best
and I'm finding as I'm just getting
older I'm just thinking better and I've
managed to overcome it a few times and
I'm back to a normal grip and I still
feel it quite a bit at times and you
feel that just even that very slight uh
feeling of it can sometimes impede You
by holding your hands off and not
allowing them to flow but the more you
put meaning on things Kamal the more you
you uh it can happen and the key to it
is you know golf is a situation where
your peer group's always asking you how
you're doing everyone wants to know
there's people there watching you just
get you know it's a human being feeling
like he's you know all all of the things
that Sportsmen go through that's why
they say that some of the great players
in finals have choked
it's not it's not a golf thing actually
it's a mental thing and it's something
that people say when you get the IPS you
have it all your life and it comes back
every so often and they're right
and Mark just to Allen's point when he
said amateur is seen as
is not given the correct definition uh
and it should be much more loved as a
word it's come to mean something that's
not as good as being perfect we should
reinvent what we mean by amateur and by
Hobby shouldn't we
yeah maybe the words should be different
um more sensory specific but
professional is purely means these days
paid
uh full-time paid generally an amateur
is not so there's all these great
golfers in England and the world
and the senior uh over 55 has grown a
huge amount actually in the LA it's only
in golf in the last few years that
there's so many tournaments you can play
in now whereas years ago there were
hardly any and the senior circuit uh I
mean I think a lot of the amateurs would
would they're not doing it for money you
see because a lot of them a lot of them
are retired and have made their money so
that I'm sure if they were really good
enough if they were the I suspect the
top in the top two only in the whole
country that's the difference between
Pro and amateur the senior Pros were
Pros when they were young and they're
that much better and the best best
amateurs I'm sure have tried to go into
the major pro events and they just
wouldn't be good enough thanks so much
Mark what a final few thoughts I'll just
come around to everyone on this call now
it's been such an excellent listen to so
much of uh what you said now Alan in
your book you include a quote from Carl
Jung which concludes could by any chance
culture be the meaning and purpose of
the second half of life now thinking
about what Marcus said about retirement
being an opportunity to really focus on
getting to where he's always wanted to
get to with golf could you imagine Alan
you are still in the thick not quite in
the same way as a daily newspaper but
certainly in the thick of current
affairs reporting as editor of prospect
magazine but could you imagine Alan
piano becoming a much bigger part of
your life as Maybe some other areas of
your main profession uh taper away
I can imagine it being bigger but I
would never want it to be my life
um I think I think actually the amateurs
good amateurs have the The Best of Both
Worlds
um
I think you think about Mark what what
Mark was saying about professional
golfers
actually good amateurs I I spoke to a
man called class Moser who had left
Germany before the war and he said that
the tradition there of professionals and
amateurs playing together in house music
was a great thing about Berlin in the
1930s and I get great pleasure playing
chamber music quite often with
professionals because they got a lot of
professional musicians don't enjoy their
job oh god I've got to play another mile
of five you know the Royal Festival Hall
tonight it's the 27th time I've played
Marla five but you come along and open a
bottle of wine and nobody's gonna Mark
your playing but you do it for the
companionship and the love of laying and
you have a a a drink and a conversation
at the end of the so I I would never I
think I would you know when I retire
fully I would like to play more music
but I but I would never want it to be
the main thing in my life I think the
the whole thing is to have it as a as a
deeply enriching sidebar to my life
what a great advert for a hobby Steve
you're stepping down as the senior
partner at Slaughter remain 2024 next
year do you think that music could take
a a bigger role v-roll in your life
after that I'm totally with Alan to be
honest I don't think I'd ever want it to
be the only thing in my life it's nice
as as a part of it
um and I'm and people often say well
you'll be able to spend more time on
your music and actually maybe a bit more
but I but I I want to do other things as
well and that and that is that is the
joy of it uh it would be nice to be able
to spend a bit more time but not all the
time fantastic Alan Emma Mark and Steve
what an inspiring conversation I'm now
going to go away and immediately start
practicing my Lego whilst playing the
piano with some golf on the side and a
bit of light music uh composition uh one
hobby as a final question for each of
you one sentence please the hobby you
wished you had done but you haven't
actually done yet Mark what are you
going to do is your hobby alongside your
golf which you haven't done yet that's
easy actually I bought the most amazing
electronic rolling piano uh
13 years ago and St and promised because
I'm so mad about music especially Jazz
that I've always wanted and I've never
played or read music at all but it's
sitting there I bought a course recently
online and I wanted to start playing
piano so
um yeah that's definitely on the agenda
especially for the winter
okay now Mark you said it publicly so
you must now commit to doing that uh
Alan the one hobby you haven't done it's
time for your public confession and we
will return to this to make sure you do
it in the future
um I want to make pots
my um my children I think trying to get
me to
uh take things easier and actually
bought me a potting wheel about two
years ago and um it's sitting there like
Mark's keyboard unused but I I think
that the satisfaction of using my hands
on pots would be wonderful okay Alan
that is now in the public domain so
you'll be held to account uh Steve
be a footballer but that's that is such
as Emma says such a fantasy although
spurs's performance at the moment maybe
it's not such a fantasy I might get into
the team
fantastic Steve all power to you and
Emma for the final word the hobby you've
never actually successfully done yet I
would like to have a go at felting and
then I would like to do animation with
the creatures that I create from felting
fantastic well they're four such
talented people thank you so much for
coming on the future verse podcast
foreign